دعت الحكومة البولندية إلى عقد اجتماع
لمسؤولي الأمن القومي وسط
تقارير تفيد بأن صاروخين أصاب
مزرعة في شرق بولندا بالقرب من
الملل الأوكراني حتى حوالي خمسة
كيلومترات أو نحو ذلك من الحدود الأوكرانية
لقي شخصان مصرعهما.
ومع
ذلك ، لا يزال التحقيق جاريا ، لذا لا يزال ينتظر المزيد من
التفاصيل ، لكن وزير دفاع لاتفيا
قدم تعازيه وألقى باللوم على
النظام الروسي الإجرامي ، دعني
أحضر كورت فولكر من مركز
تحليل السياسة الأوروبية
والمجلس الأطلسي كسفير سابق للولايات المتحدة
لدى الناتو.  إنه ينضم إلي الآن من
واشنطن رائعًا ليكون لديك في العرض
أولاً رد فعلك على ما
سمعناه ، وأنا أعلم أننا لا نقدم تفاصيل كافية
حتى الآن ولكن أفكارك
جيدة أه أولاً لا أعتقد أننا
يجب أن نكون  التي فاجأت بشن روسيا
كل هذه الهجمات ضد
أوكرانيا والتي قد تصيب بولندا بطريق الخطأ
وأظن أن ذلك
واضح  ما حدث لكن يقال
هذا غير مقبول أه نحن بحاجة إلى حلف
الناتو للالتقاء أه
التشاور مع الناتو المادة 4 تدعو لذلك
في حالة وجود أي مخاوف لدى أي
حلفاء بشأن الأمن وإه القيام
بعدة أشياء يجب أن نطلب
تفسيرًا منها  روسيا أه من الناحية المثالية ،
قد يخبرنا الروس أن هذا
كان حادثًا وأنهم لم
يقصدوا ضرب أراضي الناتو إذا كانوا
صامتين أو إذا لم يقولوا إنني أعتقد
أننا بحاجة أيضًا إلى تحذيرهم من أن أي
هجمات أخرى قد تكون  توليد
استجابة متناسبة من حلف شمال الأطلسي ضد
قواتهم ، وهو أمر
لا يريدونه ، لكنني أعتقد أنه يتعين علينا ألا نفشل
في الرد ، وسيكون أسوأ شيء هو
الصمت من رياضة الناتو التي أعتقد
أنها ستشجع روسيا بعد ذلك على التفكير في
أنها يمكن أن تفلت من أيدينا.